we begin this half hour with a step
toward justice for an unlikely
historical figure
on behalf of mr homer plessy we have
voted favorably today and will forward
the application on to governor john bel
edwards post
haste on friday a louisiana board voted
unanimously to pardon homer plessy his
arrest in 1892 led to the supreme
court's pleasey versus ferguson decision
that established the separate but equal
doctrine allowing states to maintain
racial segregation laws it was
overturned decades later in the landmark
brown versus the board of education case
now descendants of both plessy and
ferguson the louisiana judge who made
the initial ruling were in friday's
hearing michelle miller spoke to both of
them ahead of the ruling's 125th year
anniversary
it's a friendship two decades strong
between the descendants of two people
who changed the course of american
history i said well my name's keith
plessy i shook her hand she said i'm
phoebe ferguson and then she went on to
apologize for segregation
slavery
discrimination
you name it she was apologizing and i
had to say oh pump the brakes a little
bit
uh you didn't you were not responsible
for that it's not no longer plessy
versus ferguson it's plessy and ferguson
keith plessy is the distant cousin of an
african-american
shoemaker-turned-activist
homer plessy was tapped to challenge
what had become louisiana's newest
segregation law the separate car act of
1890. he looked
like a white person he was he was 1 8
black and he was selected to purchase
that ticket there was a
a group of people called the citizens
committee who organized that
a louisiana state judge ruled against
plessy his name
john howard ferguson when the case made
its way to the u.s supreme court all but
one justice agreed for years plessy like
ferguson was in the dark about his
ancestors
i never knew that i was related to him
phoebe how did you find out about this
well i just
got a call one day this gentleman had
purchased
my great great grandfather's house on
henry clay
and
he wanted to restore it
and he's saying you know i bought your
great great grandfather's house the
judge in plessy versus ferguson
i did not know that knowing she says got
her and plessy on a mission to doing
after being introduced by author keith
walden medley they created the plessy
and ferguson foundation we want people
to understand what legacy is and and not
to wait
until
the end of your life to understand
legacy but to understand legacy at an
early age do you ever think
what if the ruling had been different
well i think america had a chance
to mend itself or begin
at that time but instead after coming
through a bloody civil war a person like
homoplasty had to go and ride a train
and break a law
in order to get their attention
instead the highest court in the nation
sanctions separate but equal the most
disastrous decision by the supreme court
in american legal history the two think
of themselves as memory preservationists
planting markers around new orleans to
honor black resistance
like this one near the railroad tracks
where homer plessy was arrested our
unity
can make a difference
and i
am thrilled
to be a part of that i think the world
is my canvas right now
and the painting i'm gonna make
is one of peace
he was first arrested
129 years ago
so it took that long to get the pardon
such a powerful piece and a reminder of
why history is so important for people
to understand because the implications
obviously are still with us today and
the best line from that michelle's piece
we first did that a while back was when
he said it's no longer a plessy versus
ferguson it's plessy and absolutely
ferguson see what happens when we come
together there you go all right